okay beautiful so let's have you
continue defining this for us
like with here when in the dark so we
kind of talked about this
permanent cessation while conscious
okay well we'll go to the unaltered
state of consciousness so another way to
look at this
is that everything before the natural
state
which is what's already been the case um
is
an altered state of consciousness
the egoic state is an outer state of
consciousness it's insanity
psychotic you think your thoughts are
real you think you're a separate person
that's an algae state
let's take a moment to seriously make
sure that
this is being understood because this is
basically
reversing the entire paradigm of the
world on its head
so it's basically saying that the ego or
separation
and all the conditioning and attachments
of the that contracted energy
entity that is the altered state
that is the altered state of
consciousness is believing that i am a
separate
finite physical entity in a world full
of other separate finite physical
entities
that's the altered state and then that's
a really
big paradigm shift okay
well i mean moving from that to um the
outer state of mystical experiences
let's say you're
you've been eating all your life now you
took psychedelics now you think holy
[ __ ] this is so much more real
but that's also an altar state and we go
to meditation we should experience
genres and come to linear awakenings
uh even you know merging with god divine
union cosmic bliss all the stuff you
read about spirituality
from the perspective of the ego state
that is much more
true and much more spacious and much
more relaxed state
and unaltered yes but but now that's
still an altitude consciousness but yes
it's more unaltered yes it's a little
bit more outside but it's still
yeah yeah well you think there's more
altar but they're both altered
yes they're both altruistic but it's
giving you a taste of the unaltered
which is then what gives you the north
star
in the road map yeah right so after you
uh just identify for all the altered
state of consciousness and you slip into
the natural state
that's the unaltered state of
consciousness that's total sanity
because clinging on to universal mind or
the individual mind is the same thing
from the unaltered state of perfect
equanimity where all sensations are in
equal footing
you look at your past levels of
identification to realize that
attachment to the solidity of the ego
versus the attachment to the solidity of
mystical experiences actually the same
thing they both
uh create uh cleanings and suffering
that's why the buddha
said that not only do you have to let go
of the material realm
the form realm you have to let go of the
formless romps
in the golden chain yeah i like some
mystical experiences
but but i will go ahead i just i just
wanted to briefly say that
just to put a little flag in it just
that it is still
really important as people are stuck in
physicalism
to point people towards the formless to
towards conscience of course
yes yes yes that's why the stages are
there yes yes yes
you just there's some people that just
jump from like stage one to five
they [ __ ] go insane man
but here's the thing is the point that's
very important see the people who hasn't
experienced the non-experience of our
true nature
when they only have the egoic state in
the mystical experiences to compare
their experiences
with they're always going to be confused
they're always going to think that on
the uh the outer state of mystical
experiences the god consciousness on
psychedelics or meditation or
spontaneous glimpses
temporarily transcending itself they're
always going to think that's
enlightenment
yeah yeah they're always going to
confuse that with enlightenment because
they have they've only got the two outer
states to compare it from of course
the mystical experiences all the unity
consciousness yes
mystical experiences and says this is it
yeah yeah
and before you have a realization which
is the the the locking of
uh the true nature it seems
it's really really difficult to see this
because i've been trying to tell people
the difference between mystical
experiences which is the
temporarily transcendence of the self
which the self always comes back
because it's not a realization yet
versus the permanent drop in the way of
the self
with your relationship there's a huge
difference there
yeah it hasn't if you haven't had a
realization and realization can only
occur go naturally you there's no
realization on
a psychedelic trip when you're hired i
mean maybe there is but like
it's so filtered you can't extract it
right so when i keep trying to tell
people that dude there is
a difference between a realization and
an experience between dropping away of
the center
permanently versus just temporally
transcending yourself because when you
still have a center in the head
when you fix the problem no matter how
crazy this experience is
it's still going to be filtered through
whatever solidity that's in the head
if you're in the beginning of the path
the salinity is your entire body mind
once you get to the very end of the path
the solidity could be this tiny little
atom
somewhere like in the head somewhere
yeah well going to get in the way of
infinity
closing in on itself into this figure a
loop
99 and 100 is quantum
it's a different order together yeah
[Music]
oh man it's just so much of
like a relief
so so that what is what is wisdom what
is inside and wisdom
if i if i may if i may read the
i'll pull it up for people
and for people that are getting kind of
confused and scared i'll just remind you
one thing
wisdom is not something you accumulate
with the mind
or something you read in spiritual books
wisdom is taking away
all the falsehood until you're left with
what is now we talk about a lot of crazy
ships like you know
oh your awareness is going from 720 to
1080 to 4k to 360
8k you're like what the [ __ ] how do i
get that well
let me ask you is reality
panoramic at 360. if so then that's why
you are it's always been the case
it's always been the case does the
universe have a center point
if not that you don't have a center
because you're the universe it's very
simple
and this is the sentence
relief of being literally
nobody
relief of being literally nobody that is
when
you're dropping into this emptiness
you're dropping into
this no self you're dropping into slowly
into this natty state you're just kind
of dropping in peacefully and it's just
this
relief of not needing to be anyone
a relief of knowing that you're nothing
along with everything
and that you can just peacefully
relax all of the contracted conditioning
that you built up over the years of
wanting to
be seen as an individual wanting to be
seen as a somebody
although we are still that spark of the
infinite like we mentioned
but all of that contracted energy that
built up around
all the conditioning from your childhood
and all of the things of
wanting to impress other people
and to have all of this money and
success and fame and
oh if i just keep or being a spiritual
[ __ ] just exactly especially that one
has been so important for me recently
to be practicing that one more and more
of just
letting go of needing to be seen as a
spiritual content
seriously so the relief of being
literally nobody the ultimate attainment
is not entertainment
is the last layer between the nirvana is
the last layer of the dream the
brahman once you get so deep you become
brahmana
that's the last layer of the dream you
go so deep you're like calm and [ __ ] man
this is a problem and everything is
brahman but even that
could be this identified from ultimate
attainment
is non-attainment
but this is when you have the
reflexivity you can switch lenses again
on monday i'm going to use the emptyness
lights i'm going to go
i'm going to have a tinder day and this
theater day is the buddhist oh i'm going
to put on an empty list list
you can do a raisin bruh
like everything's unified mine okay we
just we just mentioned this one the
relief
of being literally nobody which is great
the
dying into the ordinary oh we haven't
mentioned that one
yeah that one's so important
really i i can't really relate to that
one from a direct experience
where you're literally it's like it's
kind of like being a permanent athlete
trip
except it's deeper than that because in
the natural state there's neither
an experience nor a mind right so it's
even deeper than my experience but it's
very similar to being on asset all the
time where
you look at anything at all you just see
the entire universe in there
you don't see infinite like zooms you
just you just it's just timeless it's
just
i don't know you can just like you know
how you're a little kid and just in a in
a sandbox
you just like playing with sand playing
with leaves
just you know looking at [ __ ] and
then there's just no time you don't have
to go anywhere and
that's that's your moment to experience
in the natural state
yeah and it it i remember
um when i was shifting into the state
when i was still kind of dissolving
when i read that i it i was like holy
[ __ ] this is exactly what it feels like
because it
it literally feels like you're you're
every moment is like disjointed right
and each moment you're being reborn and
being reincarnated
and each moment when you look at like i
was swiping my um
i was wiping my ass and then i was like
looking at my poop and i could
i could feel like just my sense of self
just come even the last back of it just
completely dying into the
into the toilet paper and there's
nothing but the toilet paper you know
what i mean
and but then as long as i move the
toilet that's another a new dimension in
the last one and then you kind of look
at this a little bit where you
literally every moment it feels like
you're really dying into this disjointed
frame
and then after a while it just becomes
uh more stabilized and
once you're all dead you don't feel like
you're dying anymore yeah
that's why you feel the most alive
you transcend the duality distance
between life and death gosh and don't
fear this process of dying
know that it's a natural part of the
spiritual awakening
and that it's only going to make you an
even better steward and shepherd of the
reality awakening to its nature
it'll only make you more
pure in the process yeah yeah
well spiritual speaking of the process
again there are two major shifts on the
spiritual path one is the move
from ego to being the move from ego to
awareness or consciousness or god
all that's being stuff the second move
which is
that that's that's painful that's dying
for a lot of people that's
you know that's literally death right
that's very difficult dark nights dark
nights after dark nights
the second stage sorry the second phase
the second shift
from being from existence from infinity
to non-being
to nothingness that hurts even more
because you're
letting go of even god yeah that hurts
even more
because you're letting go this infinite
feel that you
thought to be you you have to decide
from that and that hurts even more
that's why most people don't make it
that far
i always say that um waking up or
dissolving the ego
is uh awakening dissolving even god
is the natural state yeah yeah
now i'm not making a claim about the
ontological existence of god or not oh
that's
completely yeah yeah yeah and you could
you could if you were just using the
word god to reference the highest or the
absolute
you could just use it to reference the
coin that we've been talking about yeah
yeah which is that one side is emptiness
the other side's infinity
yeah that's why this thing should be
because in a natural state you can call
yourself a monkey or a god or a human be
your table whatever it doesn't matter
like you go start the difference is
during the during the god phase
i can feel my ego popping up when i look
at the word god
or when i communicate with another
spiritual khan and we're talking about
god realization i could feel my ego
popping up
this is because we associated the word
god with the capital s
self this is why versus if you
also were to associate god with
emptiness
or with no self or with tao or the natty
state
then you could say that this is god
in the shape of the coin of emptiness
and infinity
with the you could say consciousness or
awareness as this
primary attribute of the power to know
yeah so so in the natural state you
could
when i say i am god or i am awareness or
a monkey or i'm thinking
it makes absolutely no difference
there's no trigger
there's no preference there's no
contraction of any of these there it is
that's the only difference really but
it's all the same the difference the
contraction identification yes
that's it yes beautiful yeah so we're
not ruling any stages
okay the disappearing into the dark
light of the absolute you said this was
a nisargadatta the maharaja
phrase yeah uh adeshante also used the
dark light to
describe no self um because like we said
before it's almost it's the combination
of
infinity versus nothingness yeah so it's
dark and light
beautiful both disappearing and dying
into
the extraordinary while manifesting this
infinite consciousness
and field of experience perfect then
let's do life [ __ ] itself and closing
the infinity loop
uh well closing the infinity loop is the
point of making about how if there's
still
a solidity in the body mind or anywhere
in the field of experience
um infinity cannot uh fully
comprehend itself thoroughly yes yes you
know how
the logo or the animation of uh of the
figure eight or the snake
cosmic state fighting for oral boros yes
yes yeah it's going infinitely like this
right
if there's a speck in there it won't
close it won't close
yeah so even that little bit of
even if it's at the level of
even if you've popped beyond the egoic
separation conditioning to
even awareness or you know consciousness
consciousness it says even if even if
you're there
that um even if you've started to taste
a little bit of infinity and emptiness
and when i if you've tasted it
you'll still have these bits of the
supper
self that are there and this is what
you're referencing perpetually which is
the difference between
getting to the point of sort of like 99
percent
dissolving that all the way down to that
yeah
100 percent yeah that's the difference
between you as a separate entity having
an experience
of awareness consciousness or the divine
versus just reality being itself
that's how you feel about it okay it's
not a separate entity
having the realization of the divine
but it's life recognizing
the divine yeah just life being itself
life being itself
yeah saying anything about you know this
process is saying too much even saying
infinity penetrating itself
eternity gazing back itself it's saying
a little bit too much
okay yeah cool that that we just covered
that as well
and that's the difference between like
you know how people get into the later
stages of genres they get
they do get into infinite consciousness
but the teacher will tell them hey
you're still stuck in the golden chain
of the formless wrong because they're
experiencing infinite consciousness
as a meditator first dissolution of the
meditator
where this only yeah exactly
so rather than having the experience of
the divine
as a separate entity it's life itself
just yeah that's it just that's it again
is the difference between transcendence
of the self
which is the quick glimpse and this
glimpse lost sometimes for months
or five seconds versus the permanent
drop in the way of the self
yeah beautiful and life [ __ ] itself
also is deeply
at play with dependent origination as
well
that it collapses the witness
the witnessing and the witnessed into
one
and that's what this uni locality
yeah so depending on raging ace is very
interesting because
it's basically the notion that
everything's interconnected everything's
interpenetrated and everything is
you know codependent rising right so
without a u there there won't be me here
and we're all connected to infinite webs
of conditioning right
and the reason why dependent origination
is never talked about
is because without realizing emptiness
and no self you cannot perceive
dependent origination in real time and
then
without perceiving dependent origination
in real time
you're always going to be standing on
the ground for example
the move from ego to consciousness is
understanding that
the self the thinker the ego is just
another thought
right before you used to think that the
the frank yang is the thinker
and this thing is talking about thoughts
but then after streaming entry you
realize that this frankie character this
avatar
is just another thought no different
from any other thoughts it's not the
generator of thoughts
it's not the creator of thought it's not
the thinker it's in itself it's just
another thought that's empty with no one
behind it
popping in and out of nothing no
different from any other thought
that's stream entry to move from
instrumentary to
the later stages you have to apply that
process of self-inquiry
into the big self into even the god mind
now if dependent origination is true
then consciousness or the ground of
being whatever ground of being
that you identify yourself with either
the skymind or brahman
that's also dependent originating
because consciousness
is the result of the dependent
origination
between the observer perception
uh the object of perception it's
dependent on
all kinds of stuff to be able to you
know generate this experience of
consciousness